it's an animal with an identity crisis
well you hold us this is actually Kaleo
a Myna bird and his owner Colette from
Hawaii and Hawaii and Kaleo means boys
so what's the biology behind this turkey
talker what's impressive about Myna
birds is not just their ability to speak
but also their ability to learn when
they're in the wild it's the older birds
who make alarm calls to let all the
birds know that a Predator is
approaching and the juvenile birds have
to be able to hear and learn that alarm
call so that they themselves can make it
when they become older minor birds can
learn their calls or learn to vocalize
throughout their whole lives but there's
a critical period before about age six
months and this minor bird was found as
a fledgling and raised by a person
hearing human speech before six months
so as an adult minor bird it's really
learned how to speak like a human how is
this possible surely Birds can't speak
and understand human there are a lot of
birds that can imitate human speech but
minor birds kind of sound the most like
humans and that has to do with a pitch
and the frequency of the sounds that
they make but even though it sounds like
human speech their vocal apparatus is
very different from that of a human
being they have what's called a syrinx
which branches out into two to get air
down into the lungs but it's very very
small and this is why we hear bones
trilling at high frequencies but the
minor bird can actually make frequencies
that are much lower like we humans make
and this is because it's got an extra
membrane that changes the sound as the
air flows over it and that means that
whilst you can still make bird-like
sounds it can also make sounds with a
similar pitch and similar frequency to
those that we dissociate with human-like
noises
no Khalil no you're not